bonsoir 1 après le premier confinement
ce sont les vaccins qui sont au coeur de
la stratégie vaccinale normalement
normalement parce qu'on a appris cet
après-midi qu'astrazeneca qui permettait
d'accélérer la vaccination a été stoppé
après plusieurs cas de complications
avérées un peu partout en europe annonce
faite cet après midi par emmanuel macron
la france s'aligne donc sur d'autres
pays européens qui avait déjà mis en
garde et arrêter le vaccin anglo suédois
nous sommes en guerre avait lancé
emmanuel macron il ya un an
un an après où en est-on et comment
peut-on imaginer l'avenir quand on est
dirigeant politique et c'est ce dont on
va parler ce soir avec notre invité
olivier faure pour soir bonsoir
et premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste et député de seine et marne
avec nous pendant une heure d'audition
publique sur lcp public sénat avec le
figaro c'est votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire on va parler donc de
l'actualité immédiate à ce que la
suspension pardon de la vaccination
astrazeneca en france est-ce que c'était
la meilleure décision à prendre
je comprends qu'il ya une inquiétude il
faut pouvoir la levée je crois que d'ici
à mercredi
elle le sera ce que je sais c'est qu'il
a 17 millions de personnes qui ont été
vaccinées avec ce vaccin que
quelques-unes ont fait une thrombose
mais chaque année ce sont trois cent
mille personnes qui sont victimes de
thrombose dans notre pays donc bon il
faut rester prudent bien sûr mais ne pas
non plus céder à une forme de panique
que l'on peut comprendre parce qu'une
fois nous sommes face à des vaccins qui
sont récents mais la réalité c'est qu'il
ya certainement une conjonction souvenez
vous pour le kaiser
l'an passé c'était la même chose on
avait aussi cru que le kaiser conduisait
à la mort immédiate grâce à nombre de
patients les études ont montré l'inversé
quand vous dites il faut pas céder à la
panique en l'occurrence qui cèdent à la
panique là je dis simplement que je vois
qu'aujourd'hui ces droits qui c'était la
panique
l'adea nombre de pays qui ont souhaité
suspendre peut-être pour rassurer leur
population y compris la france voit
quelqu'un je cima c'est normal mais
attention parce que la trainée cas c'est
un million de doses par semaine
donc si vous suspendez pendant une
semaine 5 millions de vaccins en moins
deux semaines ces deux millions et ainsi
de suite
or stratégie française elle repose
notamment sur astrazeneca puisque
avons rien d'autre rien d'autre donc la
réalité c'est l'odeur m'accorde ainsi
nous voulons construire une stratégie
vaccinale et dans tout éviter en fait le
pire c'est à dire de tout bloquer dans
ce pays
ça suppose de vacciner est ce que je
comprends pas c'est que je ne comprends
pas si vous trouvez qu'il fallait
prendre cette décision de stopper ou pas
et moi je pense qu'à ce stade rien
n'indique que la troisième n'est qu'à
souhaite un problème mais si c'est la
sphère de deux jours je l'entends je le
comprends parfaitement il faut parfois
rassurer et donc grâce à eux ça peut
entraîner la panique au contraire parce
que le doute sur les vaccins ça va être
pire encore non il faut rappeler ce que
j'aime dire à l'instant et 7 millions de
vaccins quelques cas de thrombose
chaque année 300 milles thrombose en
france dans que ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous pouvez voir
quelqu'un qui va se faire vacciner et
ensuite est victime d'une thrombose est
ce qu'il ya un lien entre la cause et
l'effet moi je ne le crois pas mais je
ne suis pas scientifique et c'est pas à
moi de le dire alors il y en a une qui
le dira c'est l' agence européenne du
médicament exact c'est à dire si c'est
bon ou pas d'ici 48 heures à peu près
est-ce qu'on peut encore faire confiance
confiance à cette agence européenne du
médicament
pourquoi pas en fait heureusement que
enfin moi je suis quand même
pandémie comme celle-là qu'on évite en
permanence de créer le même le doute il
y à une instance qui est chargé pour
l'union européenne valider ou pas les
vaccins il faut déjà confiance jusque là
ça c'est en cause on met pas le plan
européen on pense ya déjà suffisamment
de choses à remettre en cause on l'est
on y reviendra tout à l'heure justement
avec brigitte boucher thème traduit qui
sont avec nous comme the gazette
histoire bonsoir brigitte doit faire
face il est bon soir voir s'affronter
c'est simplement public fait la wii par
ailleurs le même laboratoire astrazeneca
avait déjà annoncé des retards dans les
livraisons de vaccins
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps pour la
france d'aller voir ailleurs d'aller
voir vers d'autres vaccins vaccin russe
le vaccin chinois par exemple pour
pouvoir tenir les objectifs de
vaccination si bien sûr mais j'espère
qu'il n'y a pas de partages idéologie
nous sommes dans un moment où il faut
jamais dire ça fait tout bois c'est pas
une expression mais l'idée est celle là
c'est que il faut aller chercher les
remèdes là où ils existent pour
l'instant jusqu'ici les russes et
chinois avait refusé de donner en fait
dans ce cas de fabrication pour
permettre
justement cette agence du médicament de
vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas de contre
indications et face à dole a donc
réalisé les russes viennent de se
soumettre à ce processus
je ressens un médicament et donc je
crois comprendre qu'il s'appellera pas
soutenu qu'en europe
je sais pas comme on l'appellera ariane
j'espère enfin peut-être mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est une bonne chose
c'est pas il faut s'ouvrir au vaccin sûr
y'a pas de deux questions idéologiques
là dedans
il ne faut pas qu'il y en ait surtout
faut pas qu'ils en aient enfin peu
importe que le chat soit noir ou blanc
du moins qui attrape la souris disait
mao zedong olive et fort la situation
est assez préoccupante et inquiétante
c'est ce qu'elle a dit le premier
ministre jean castex emmanuel macron on
dit également que nous aurons des
décisions nouvelles à prendre dans les
prochains jours vous vous êtes député de
seine-et-marne vous êtes directement
concernés est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut confiné en ile de france
d'abord ce que je demande au
gouvernement et vous noterez que depuis
un an j'ai toujours dit la même chose
moi j'ai toujours été d'accord pour non
pas être la polémique gratuite mais
chercher avec le gouvernement quels
étaient les bonnes pistes et donc je
souhaite que tout soit mis sur la table
pour que nous puissions prendre les
bonnes décisions et moi je m'engage au
nom de mon parti à faire en sorte que si
nous arrivons à une décision conjointe
nous l'assumons avec le gouvernement pas
simplement être toujours l'opposition
qui râlent qui comptait c'était à moi je
suis vous souhaitez être consultés ce
que vous demandez en fait je souhaitais
que la vente où sont mises sur la table
parce que tu veux c'est à dire mais ces
chiffres tout les chiffres et le nez
comment vous expliquer par exemple que
les notes du conseil scientifique qui
avait été il ya un an présenté comme
l'instance de régulation par excellence
et c'est maintenant ils font des notes
on ne les accueille trois semaines un
mois trop d'incidence en ile de france
on connaît les personnes en réanimation
les hospitalisations
vous n'avez pas suffisamment de données
pour sa besoin aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
finisse mes besoins et comprendre
qu'elles sont parce que il faut mêler de
stratégie ratée j vaccinale et puis
éventuellement le confinement comprendre
ce que serait l'impact des mesures que
nous prendrions sur les uns sur les
autres
l'impact de l'impact psychologique
puisque en cause assure-t-il qu'il avait
maintenant désormais des psychologues
vous savez moi j'ai besoin d'avoir
toutes ces données là pour pouvoir faire
la part d'ubs
à part du lion et comprendre à la fin ce
que nous pouvons prendre une décision il
est fort ce que j'espère c'est vu les
évacuations de malades par exemple vers
des hôpitaux partout en france vous avez
vu les cas comme dit brigitte
d'occurrence qui augmente ça vous suffit
pas pour dire il faut re confiné du de
france je voudrais avoir les études
d'impact vous avez vous voyez des rentes
à 40,60 les programmations voit ce qui
se passe je comprends que nous sommes
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
fin pénible pour les soignants terrible
pour les familles et pour les malades
la co lead et donc oui il faut un mois
je suis prêt à assumer y compris des
mesures difficiles dans l'opinion qu'ont
fait un recond finement d'ile-de-france
su prêt à assumer toutes les décisions
qui s'imposeront à une condition c'est
que très hallab le mans nous ayons
toutes les données qui permettent de
comprendre quel est l'impact des mesures
que nous prenons ça n'est pas normal que
nous ne sachions pas que tout sera sur
la table et que nous avions condamné
finalement pour l'instant dans
l'impression qu'on est à poursuivre les
paris du président moi je ne suis pas là
pour suivre les paris du président je
suis là pour faire en sorte que les
françaises et les français puissent
vivre en sécurité sur le précédent signé
en l'occurrence dernier en tout cas
jusqu'ici le gouvernement a tenté de ne
par confiner les de france la ligne a
été de dire que chaque jour sans
confinement est un jour de gagné
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cela
ce que c'était un jour de gagné non je
ne pense pas je ne pense pas comme ça je
pense que justement c'est ce que je
viens de dire c'est que moi je ne suis
pas là pour faire des paris
mais là pour faire moi j'ai dû solitude
du dur je veux que les gens comprennent
que ce qu'on fait est la meilleure
solution
alors est ce que le mien prudente de la
part du gouvernement de dire qu'on gagne
à chaque fois à paris et comme tous les
paris un jour on gagne un jour on perd
en l'occurrence atenor l'occurrence ya
paris perdus ou c'est pas ça veut dire
que malheureusement effectivement on a
aujourd'hui un président qui considèrent
qu'ils les épidémiologistes qui les
médecins qui est enfin il est tout
puisqu'en fait il est omniscient
donc il sait tout et il prend la
décision tout seul moi je soutiens m 2
les gens créent des décisions liées fort
alors qu'ils essaient de pari perdu
alors
mais je ne sais pas encore simplement ce
que je sais c'est que ce que je vois
c'est que parfois quand on confine tôt
eh bien on confine moins longtemps que
contre fille confine tard et que là on a
un problème est que le vario engrais
notamment qui est 70% des nouvelles
contaminations c'est pas rien concentric
60% plus létal plus mortels et qu'il est
60% plus contagieux donc ça devrait vous
faire réfléchir et je me souviens très
bien
à l'époque où jean castex avait
accueilli tous les présidents de groupe
à l'assemblée
l'avionnais des graphiques étaient
terrifiants d'ailleurs qui ne se sont
pas vérifiées mais des graphiques qui
m'ont très bien qu'il y avait un risque
est aujourd'hui nous sommes
effectivement avec un taux d'incidence
qui est au deuil seuils d'alerté et donc
oui il faut maintenant agir
il a suppose que nous ayons une
consultation avec les avec les maires
avec des gens départements et de régions
et que nous ayons des mesures
territorialisée aussi parce que je ne
crois pas qu'il faille considérer
l'ensemble de ce pays comme un seul bloc
visite
on est à un an à peu près jour pour jour
après le début de la crise et le premier
confinement à l'époque emmanuel macron
déclarait nous sommes en guerre
est ce que vous diriez qu'il a gagné
peut-être pas gagné la guerre mais au
moins une bataille
moi je sais pas un fait moi je n'ai
jamais compris ce au vocabulaire parce
qu' il n'était pas non pas que nous ne
nions pas une guerre à mener contre le
virus mais parce que si c'est la guerre
dans ces cas là il fallait en prendre
les moyens or j'ai eu le sentiment sur
les masques sur les tests sur le vaccin
nous étions toujours en retard si
vraiment nous faisons la guerre comme on
a su en à gérer l'épidémie de colline
pardon mais enfin nous n'aurions jamais
gagné aucune ne soyons aujourd'hui donc
il a perdu peu encore il a perdu si on
considère je croise des tests l'eba
chaque fois heureusement les
collectivités locales par exemple sur la
vaccination ont pris le relais le monde
hospitalier et donc heureusement nous
sommes dans un pays où tout ne dépend
pas du chef de l'état quoiqu'il en pense
mais il pas quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
quoi qu il en pense quoi qu'ils en
pensent et donc mais il n'empêche que à
chaque fois
et bien que nous avons toujours été en
retard et que nous n'avons jamais réussi
à anticiper et génériques aujourd'hui
par exemple ils prennent encore la tâche
d'aider des maires notamment pour
pouvoir savoir ce qu'on met en place
n'est pas tout le monde ne vit pas la
même façon mais moi ce que la france on
n'a pas tous les mêmes réalités
les français ne sont pas convaincus par
le gouvernement un sondage au doxa le
figaro montre que deux tiers d'entre eux
sont très critiques à l'égard de la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement mais ils sont encore plus
nombreux
à être critique à l'égard des
oppositions 84% d'entre vous n'avez pas
été au rendez-vous de cette crise
sanitaire vous les oppositions moi je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire les
oppositions quand on fait des sondages
où on demande aux gens non mais les
choux et la route ensemble on dit
maintenant
donnez nous votre avis sur les choux et
les carottes est ce que vous avez à les
choux et les carottes votre collègue au
gouvernement en l'occurrence moi je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire les
oppositions moi ce que je sais c'est que
l'opposition que je représente elle a
cherché à chaque étape
être responsable à se faire entendre
nous avons alerté sur la question la
fantaisie vaccinale en novembre moi j'ai
écrit le 11 novembre précisément ces
consultable par tous et toutes les
questions qui ensuite ont été posées par
la presse par etc à parler français zone
à eux-mêmes et à chaque fois j'étais
pierre-janet balam essayer de comprendre
pourquoi nous ne faisions pas à temps et
je vais pas fait le lendemain pour dire
à regarder ils sont tombés non je le dis
avant pour prévenir le gouvernement et
lui dire voilà maintenant vous avez les
questions posées
répondez-nous géré poser les questions
directement à jean castex dans les
réunions que j'ai eue avec lui il ne m'a
jamais répondu je le regrette parce que
toutes ces questions elle était non
seulement opérante
mais elle aurait évité de prendre
l'ornière à chaque fois donc oui je
pense que nous avons été au rendez vous
à chaque étape nous avons cherché à le
faire dans un de nos clients un esprit
de solidarité nationale
il ya une issue éventuellement à cette
crise c'est le passeport vert qui
pourrait être mis en place dès cet été
qui est portée est annoncée par thierry
breton commissaire européen au marché
intérieur est ce qu'il faut le faire
pour vous mais je comprends pas très
bien l'objet parce que en fait bien sûr
on vous a dit d'abord que c'était pas
obligatoire le vaccin donc là s'il avait
un passeport ça le rend obligatoire
premières indications données ne
seraient pas que le vaccin elle serait
aussi un test de tests pcr ou
une guérison montrer qu'on a été guérie
page a suivi croissant mais vous rendez
compte que au stade où nous en sommes à
la vitesse où nous allons nous aurons
vacciner les français en juin 2022 donc
vous avez imposé un passeport à des gens
qui voudraient être vaccinés qui ne le
peuvent les y aurait pas que le vaccin
aussi puteaux et à sa santé mais aussi
pour voyager quand même cet été sur pc
wii pour matcher le gouvernement annonce
la mise en place d'une prime alors on
avait parlé dans un premier temps d'une
prime à l'attention des travailleurs de
la seconde ligne
c'est à dire les caissiers les éboueurs
et c'est finalement ça va être une prime
jusqu'à 1000 euros défiscalisées pour
tous les salariés est ce que c'est une
bonne chose
oui c'est une bonne chose même si c'est
au bon vouloir
maintenant les entreprises et quoi on
sait très bien que mille euros c'est
l'objectif affiché est qu'elle a été
moins de la moitié la plus de temps en
moyenne dans l'ensemble d'entreprises
françaises donc obliger toutes les
entreprises à s'en emparer de cette
possibilité une communication habile
l'on vous dise la prime de 1000 euros
en réalité elle sera de 3 ans soit 2 300
400 euros et rien dire les pivots là est
malheureusement à la matière l'état n'a
pas donné l'exemple parce que pour la
fonction publique j'étais cette semaine
vasana n'ya pas donc avec les sages
femmes qui manifestaient 2 on lire dans
la santé vous rendez compte que les
sages femmes qui ont dû continuer à
coucher pendant le premier confinement
que le second confinement elles n'ont
même pas obtenu la prime des soignants
parce qu'elles sont considérées comme du
personnel administratif alors qu'elle
était elle aussi avec les sacs poubelles
sur le dos quand il fallait accoucher
dans l'est les conditions que l'on sait
avec pénurie un masque de blues de tout
ce que vous voulez donc l'effet de
communication il faudrait que faiblement
quoi se mettre au niveau et un site
justement tout le monde à en faire de
même
ainsi tout oblige je préférerais que non
mais là vous me demandez enfin toutes
les entreprises sont pas logés à la même
enseigne
je peux pas non plus je dis simplement
que la merci de communication dont 10000
euros il faut dire jusqu'à 1000 euros
vous serez défiscaliser la réalité si on
est honnête c'est de dire que cette
prime sera
très largement inférieurs dans la
plupart des cas et que parfois elle
pourra atteindre 1000 euros et même 0
c'est arrivé même 0 on peut parler j'ai
pas dire que c'est mal c'est plutôt
mieux que voilà celle ci c'est bien mais
soyons honnêtes sur sa communication
on va parler dans la logique du climat
oui parce que demain les députés vont
voter la révision constitutionnelle pour
inscrire la garantie de la protection de
l'environnement à l'article 1er de la
constitution
que vont faire les députés ps que
vont-ils voter voter pour on va voter
tour parce que nous sommes laborde
fidèle à ce que la conscience citoyenne
avait pu proposer mais je dois mettre un
codicille c'est que on va voter pour
mais ça ne servira pas à grand chose en
réalité il n'y aura pas de référendum a
au bout c'est même pas que la vocation
du référendum c'est que le texte tel
qu'il est rédigé n'est pas une
amélioration significative de ce qui
existe déjà vous avez déjà une charte de
l'environnement qui a droit
constitutionnel et qui dit la même chose
donc vous allez avoir un texte de plus
qui n'apporte rien il aurait été
intéressant de rajouter par exemple à
cet article 1er un principe de non
régression pour éviter par exemple que
sur les néonicotinoïdes et bien puisse
pas revenir dessus
or malheureusement vous pouvez voter
tout texte que vous voulez si en plus
derrière vous n'avez pas un dispositif
légal qui lui-même vient en soutien on a
plus de cette conscience de cette
constitution ça ne sert à rien donc ça
ne sert à rien et de référendum
vous n'en sais rien vous paraissent ils
devenus ce que la droite veut faire au
sénat mais là aussi c'est quand même
beaucoup de communication pour pas grand
chose
voter oui dans la même veine que le
projet loi puisque je vous dis que nous
allons voter oui à l'assemblée je vois
mal comment on dirait on va tous et à la
santé vous savez les contradictions
parfois ça
mieux préciser vaut mieux préciser mais
moi je suis enfin j'essaie de vous faire
comprendre depuis le début que j'essaye
de faire de la politique avec sincérité
avec honnêteté je sais bien ça peut
surprendre mais c'est comme ça moi je
souhaite que nous soyons clair cohérent
ce que je suis depuis trois ans jusqu'en
et secrétaires table on va aussi parler
de la loi climat qui est issu de la
convention citoyenne
elle vient en débat vous avez déposé au
départ près de 500 amendements sur ce
texte
à quelles conditions voterez-vous cette
seule loi c'est plutôt enfin là aussi
j'ai l'impression de me répéter beaucoup
cette émission parce que il a beaucoup
d'affichage
on a un gouvernement qui maudit bon ben
c'est pas de notre faute si vous répétez
un joli coup du gouvernement qui fait
l'affiché à la cause du gouvernement on
a eu peur je voyais bien sûr mais c'est
malheureux à dire que nous sommes enfin
vous redonnez que ce texte s'il vient en
fait après une convention citoyenne qui
elle même vient après ce fameux grand
débat qui vient lui-même après les gilet
jaune revient de loin
ça devait être un texte prioritaire il a
d'abord été repoussé à plusieurs
reprises il devait passer pendant
l'automne et l'hiver puis maintenant
enfin ça devait être en janvier puis
c'est l'ennui
on y est et qu'est ce qu'on y trouve
mais malheureusement on y trouve
beaucoup de choses qui sont floues
renvoyé à plus tard ou qui sont
conditionnés par tellement d'éléments
que vous savez très bien que les choses
ne se passeront pas même sur des sujets
simples pense par exemple à l'équivalent
de la loi evin sur la cigarette
désormais vous ne pouvez plus faire de
publicité pour les produits du tabac
là par exemple rien n'est clair en fait
vous pouvez continuer ne pouvait plus
faire de publicité sur les produits
directement carbonées m'enfin y'a pas de
publicité une loi fait c'est une loi de
recul pour vous si une loi
j'apprécie tu nous as de recul c'est une
loi qui est une loi insuffisante
il n'y a pas trois jockeys ya 500 aucun
dans cette loi vous ne voterez pas quoi
non je dis pas ça je n'en sais rien on
verra bien ce qui ce que seront l'issue
des débats là aussi je faisons de la
politique de manière honnête et
responsable
donc si le texte avance dans les débats
si nous sommes écoutés entendus repris
je voterai la loi la condition vous y
croyez j'y crois j'essaye à chaque fois
que je rentre dans cet hémicycle avec
mes collègues j'ai c'est le crois que ce
gouvernement va peut-être 1
jours derrière ce qu'ils avaient promis
c'est à dire écoutez jours et la droite
et la gauche pour l'instant on a compris
qu'il n'écoutait que lui même aurait dit
tout le monde peut rêver dans ce projet
loi climat il y a la volonté d'installer
une taxe carbone pour les camions mais
ce serait les régions qu'il installerait
et seulement celles qui le veulent
valérie pécresse est d'accord pour
l'installer en ile de france vous en
ile-de-france pour les régionales vous
soutenez audrey pulvar est ce que le
sait la position du ps finalement est ce
que le ps est d'accord pour la mettre en
oeuvre
moi je soutiens cette position déjà dans
le quinquennat précédent au moment où a
été abandonnée là un texte qui a
maintenant la taxe carbone les portiques
et hors taxes l'écotaxe et je souhaitais
effectivement qu'on puisse permettre aux
régions qui le souhaitent et qui
investissent beaucoup pour les routes
pour un réseau qui soient en bon état et
qu'ils vont à des canons passé et qui ne
tire aucun profit donc oui je souhaite
effectivement que celles et ceux qui
polluent qui détruisant ses
infrastructures d'un les paye aussi
région par région ça c'est possible oui
c'est possible d'accord alors deux
dernières questions une question de tam
concernant les rixes qu'on avait les
rixes entre jeunes qui se multiplient
notamment en ile-de-france qui sont de
plus en plus violente avec des jeunes de
plus en plus jeunes qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour lutter vous contre ce
phénomène on a entendu valérie pécresse
qui veut des police municipale armée
laurent saint martin qui veut une police
régionale qu'est ce que vous vous
proposez
mais je les écoute je suis stupéfait on
va armer les polices municipales parce
que vous voulez tirer sur les jeunes qui
sont en train de se battre pour liste
régionale on a déjà une police nationale
la police municipale il faut une police
régionale aussi pour qu'il y ait encore
plus de 17 à 9 ces gens sont sont pas
raisonnables
en fait il faut effectivement renforcer
la police nationale et la continuer à
faire ce que nous avons nous fait un
précédent quinquennat cr revenir sur les
13 mai les suppressions de postes sous
le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy et
continuer à avancer
mais ce qu'il faut aussi parce qu'on le
sait bien la question c'est pas
simplement la grèce est trop tard la
répression en fait vous pouvez toujours
réprimées mais le mal est fait ce qu'il
faut c'est ce procès jeunes
était ce week-end avec une association
avec laquelle on va travailler ensemble
justement pour faire en sorte que c'est
bien on les connaît les bornes le pire
c'est pas que ces salles mais ça ne
vient pas nous les noirs c'est pas
nouveau c'est plus violents qu'avant
mais on sait très bien que ces bandes à
des existe on connaît les jeunes on sait
qui sont les meneurs ont center et donc
comment est ce qu'on fait pas avant
qu'il ne passe à l'acte a tout
simplement on cherche à faire en sorte
que par exemple la rivalité s'exprime
sur un autre terrain que celui de la
violence
ça peut être on les fait voyager
ensemble en effet se rencontrer sur un
terrain de foot ont tous deux policiers
aussi avez vous dit quand même tout
allait bien sûr recréer des deux
policiers bien sûr que là il faut
assurer une sécurité et moi je ne suis
pas de ceux qui pensent que il ya
uniquement à la prévention
ses deux pieds la prévention et la
sanction mais sur la prévention et j
insiste parce que personne n'en parle or
c'est essentiel on sait très bien que en
fait si on ne fait rien ce sont souvent
des jeunes qui sont un peu lâchés et qui
sont finalement le résultat de nos modes
de vie avec départs en vacances avait
une maman mère célibataire qui travaille
j'allais rencontrer une autre jour tenez
vous bien à la 7 heures de transport par
jour en région parisienne pour aller
faire le ménage dans toute la région
elle a quatre enfants ben vous pensez
qui c'est qui les élèvent les enfants
il scelle tout seul donc ces enfants là
si vous n'avez pas des médiateurs si
vous n'avez pas des associations si vous
avez pas des gens qui sont là pour venir
en soutien de cette mer et qui viennent
aussi à tout simplement leur expliquer
les règles de la vie qui viennent tout
simplement leur expliquer aussi qu' on
peut effectivement considérer que de
clélia des boutons le village d'en face
c'est pas terrible
enfin il vaut mieux se lancer dès
évoluent le lance-pierre plutôt que la
batte de base-ball ou le coup l'armé
blanche selon l'avocat pour ce dossier
une autre question plus sensible qu'est
société tout autre sujet le 8 avril une
proposition de loi sera proposé à
l'assemblée nationale du par le groupe
liberté et territoires pour légaliser
l'euthanasie en france est ce que vous
vous y être favorables j'y suis
favorable
non pas que ce soit pour moi
une religion ou même un modèle que
souhaite imposer à qui que ce soit mais
nous sommes une république laïque et
donc ça suppose que chacune et chacun
fasse ses choix de vie et en
l'occurrence de mort selon sa propre
conscience
au nom de quoi irions nous dicter aux
uns ou aux autres
les conditions de ce que peut être la
fin de leur vie moi je n'utilise jamais
le terme de mort dans la dignité et de
mourir dans la dignité parce que ça
relève de chacun je comprends
parfaitement qu'il ya des gens qui
considèrent que la souffrance puissent
être aussi une part de la vie peut-être
c'est qu'il ya des révisions c'est la
rédemption de lettres qu'on cherche à
atteindre par ce canal là j'en sais rien
mais ce que je sais c'est que personne
ne peut imposer à qui que ce soit en
faisant de valeurs qui lui sont propres
donc croyances qui lui sont propres ne
peut imposer aux zones liberté de vote
dans mais moi je pense qu'il faut de la
liberté tout court
la conscience est toujours notée de vote
bien ce que je souhaite surtout c'est
que on y parviennent enfin et je
tiendrai une conférence de presse le 23
mars prochain avec systems et ceux qui
dans les groupes différents de
l'asssemblée sont prêts à lancer et moi
je souhaite une grande loi de liberté
oui j'ai entendu hôtel merci merci tu as
dit évidemment à propos tout on va
rester sur cette histoire de thé nazis
cette affaire d'euthanasie
ça me fasse guérini hier le numéro un de
la république en marche à proposer une
autre méthode pour permettre aux
français de s'exprimer sur un tel sujet
vous allez entendre
moi je crois que la bonne méthode c'est
celle que nous avons employé pour
adopter la pma pour toutes
c'est à dire d'avoir un calendrier qu'il
soit partagé beaucoup de clarté à un
moment de concertation nous avons mis en
place une convention style pour le
climat peut-être que ce serait utile de
mettre en place un tel outil là une
convention citoyenne pour discuter pour
créer des conditions de consensus et que
chacun puisse prendre ses
responsabilités olivier faur convention
citoyenne et autour de l'euthanasie
c'est une blague
enfin est-ce que vraiment on a besoin
que les français se prononcent mais
c'est pas ici a pas un écart de 2 % dans
les sondages
c'est 97% en croit des françaises et
français aujourd'hui qu'ils souhaitent
cette loi de liberté
donc qu'on fasse une commission théodule
de plus alors qu'il y en a déjà eu des
dizaines ans on sait tout ça en fait moi
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas continuer
sur la loi claisse leonetti il faut
aussi faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
soins palliatifs pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
il faut que chacun puisse trouver selon
sa conscience mais je souhaite aussi
comment expliquez-vous que une femme
comme pour les sacs une fleur qui
étaient contre ancien ministre de la
zone ancien ministre socialiste
effectivement et pascal était avec une
maladie incurable était celle de son
père dont elle savait qu'elle serait en
fait la faim qui avaient été promises et
qui donc a été obligé d'aller en suisse
pour faire le choix de mourir
moi je souhaite que ce choix là ils sont
possibles y compris en france pour bien
vous voulez vous imposez à qui que ce
soit une morale qui n'est pas la sienne
bien ont maintenant extraire nous a
rejoint bof arrive
bonsoir francis on va changer un peu de
rose y sont apparus voilà est un peu
plus juste si on veut dans certains
situations qui arrivent des élections
régionales est parti socialiste jour os
puisqu'il préside plusieurs précisions
dans notre pays ce matin sur public
sénat benoît hamon un ancien du parti
socialiste dit eh ben moi j'appelle à ce
que l'union de la gauche fins derrière
le candidat écologiste en ile-de-france
qui s'appelle julien bayou est ce que
vous allez demander à audrey pulvar de
se ranger derrière la tête de liste
europe écologie verts
alors j'ai entendu aussi quelqu'un ce
matin qui est stable bassin l'écologie
de la crise un triste et qui elle a dit
qu'elle était prête à se ranger derrière
audrey pulvar donc à la discussion on
peut commencer bon moi je ne suis pas
opposé cette discussion est là pour tout
vous dire je vais souhaiter depuis le
début et j'ai dit à julien bayou faisons
en sorte que chacun selon ses points
forts puisse arriver quelque chose et
qu'on puisse unir nos forces plutôt que
nos diviser j'ai entendu ce matin eric
piolle ou dimanche eric faye qui dit en
fait en auvergne orientons ne veut pas
aller d'ailleurs national opel cassen
parce que nous avons gagné
lyon grenoble et annecy en ile-de-france
où sont les villes gagnées à par colombe
ap quelles sont les villes gagnées par
les écologistes paris c'est socialiste
et que je vous dis de paris parce que
c'est tellement significatif mais tant
d'autres villes de shakti dont à savigné
l'union derrière audrey pulvar alors ce
serait assez logique par exemple de dire
dans une île de france
prenons audrey pulvar parce qu'elle est
la mieux placée pour l'emporter
peut-être que dans d'autres régions et
d'autres personnes qui peuvent être soit
un écologiste sa carrière la société
civile soit quelqu'un moi j'ai pas de
gégé pas de problème avec ça
ce que je dis simplement c'est qu'il
faut arrêter de dire oui au
rassemblement mais la ressemblance est
toujours derrière moi derrière moi étant
chacun sachant au logiciel socialiste et
ses récents en parle on va parler de la
présidentielle tout à l'heure que vous
aviez dit que c'était pas nécessairement
un socialiste qui devait représenter la
gauche à la présidentielle
on va y accueillir le meilleur ou la
meilleure dans les hauts de france là
vous avez réussi à faire l'union avec un
homme d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient toute la
légitimité pour être numéro un qui
s'appelle patrick kanner sénateur
socialiste ancien ministre et non c'est
karima delli l'écologiste qui va
conduire la liste dans laquelle on
retrouve on va retrouver normalement des
socialistes précisément des communistes
et de la france insoumise ainsi que des
écologistes quel est le but là c'est de
battre rallié bertrand est le but c'est
de faire en sorte que cette région au
niveau de francs soit une région qu'ils
soient gérés de manière plus sociale
plus écologique plus démocratique et qui
soit favorable à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes mais ce qui est le
projet commun le tronc commun entre ces
formations que vous n'êtes site et fait
donc le but i les régionales il est de
faire en sorte que demain cette région
soit echirey différemment dans une
région qui est largement pollué par
l'extrême droite qui a été la source de
beaucoup un vrai traumatisme
il y a 6 ans et donc je souhaite que ce
soit cette soirée par young imaginons
mais on n'imagine pas parce que ça
pourrait très bien se produire compte
tenu de cette union de la gauche
un deuxième tour avec monsieur bertrand
le candidat du rassemblement national et
le rassemblement de la gauche vous
maintiendrez si vous êtes qualifiés si
un risque de victoire du rassemblement
national national qu'est ce que vous
faites
moi personnellement la formation que je
dirige
nous avons toujours dit la même chose
nous ne serons pas de ceux qui font
élire le rassemblement national
si je comprends bien ça veut dire que
vous vous rendriez derrière pour le
mieux placé si c'est monsieur voit que
vous me comprenez parfaitement
je ne dirais pas plus général pak loin
parce que nous n'en sommes pas là et
bien moi je souhaite la victoire de la
liste conduite par karima delli
donc on verra bien le soin le moment
venu mais s'il n'y a pas de menace qui
entendent se retirer non plus d'accord
alors le parti socialiste
j'espère distraire on pose souvent la
question aux socialistes
j'aimerais qu'on pose la question aussi
aux républicains elle sera votée qui
sont là disent ce qu'ils sont prêts à
faire autant sortir pour la
présidentielle j'aimerais que l'ail et
bertrand par exemple le 10 pour les
autres france elle sera posée évidemment
alors le parti socialiste qui va pas
très fort sur le plan financier si j'ai
bien compris a été mieux ça a été mieux
vous allez pouvoir présenter un candidat
ou une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
votre choix va toujours vers madame
hidalgo mon choix j'ai toujours dit
c'est que nous prenions le moment venu
le ou la meilleure d'entre nous pour
incarner ce blog social et écologique et
et on m'a même socialiste effectivement
je préfère que ce soit une socialiste en
l'occurrence anne hidalgo soit la
candidate si elle se déclarait et ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais je
suis prêt à envisager toute éventualité
à une condition et une seule oui c'est
que là aussi les autres partis
politiques disent la même chose que moi
parce que c'est trop facile on peut pas
dire je veux le rassemblement mais c'est
derrière moi
non moi je suis le seul aujourd'hui à
gauche à dire je prends mon risque
ouais je prends mon risque je ne sais
pas qui sera le meilleur ou la meilleure
qui le sait mais en revanche ce que je
sais c'est que le plus gros risque que
j'ai à prendre pour l'information
politique et plus encore pour le pays
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de candidat de gauche
et de l'écologie au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle et donc
j'essaie d'être responsable et unitaire
pour 5 pour 10 pour 15
icahn a ras-le-bol de cette gauche qui
prétend que macro cet affreux marine le
pen c'est insupportable mais on fait
tout pour se dérouler le tapis rouge
alors soit on pense que le réchauffement
climatique on a dix ans seulement pour
réparer la planète et dans ces cas-là on
s'y met maintenant soit on arrête de le
dire et on fait ben on dit bon c'est pas
très grave on peut se désunir encore moi
je ne comprends pas ces gens qui vous
disent je ne peux pas marre assemblée
avec les gens qui sont plus proches de
moi alors ces cas-là vous récents de las
vegas il voulait gouverner
est-ce que sur madame hidalgo vous
n'avez pas été un peu inquiet quand même
comme beaucoup de parisiens et de france
il ya une quinzaine de jours
quand on a vu un soir c'était un jeudi
soir je crois son premier adjoint
monsieur emmanuel grégoire nous annoncer
que il demandait le confinement de paris
parce que les chiffres étaient
inquiétants et madame hidalgo le
contredire quelques jours après en
disant mais non c'était tout à fait
absurde je suis contre le confinement
dit elle même ça ça donne pas quand même
un sentiment de grande sécurité pour
quelqu'un qui veut devenir présidente de
la république peut-être je crois que son
premier agent c'était le corrigé de
lui-même
elle il avait était un peu rapide dans
son expression et compte tenu de la
sensibilité à la fois du sujet
et puis maintenant de l'attention portée
à tout ce que peut dire anne hidalgo sa
s'est embrasée un soir un jeudi soir
comme vous le dites parce que jean
castex allait lui même annoncé qu'il n'y
avait pas de confinement et donc il y
avait là une forme de contre
programmation qui a créé en fait le buzz
et qui a été bien trop fort alors je
comprends bien la question intention n'a
même pas été de tout poser ce mal et moi
je crois que du zen façon il faut tout
poser sur la table avec tous les
éléments et les valeurs mais je pense
qu'il faut que tout soit dit pour que la
bonne solution sont connus
le moment venu toujours dans la
perspective de 2022 puisque c'est
bientôt maintenant ça va bientôt arriver
près d'un an
est-ce que vous tendez la main à
monsieur jean luc mélenchon qui fait
toujours un peu la course en solitaire
dans ce genre de scrutin
moi je suis pas marin mais enfin
je suis très vendée globe donc si jean
luc mélenchon était pris dans une
tempête et que son demain a été cassé
plutôt que de continuer à courir je vais
aller chercher et son mât est cassé je
pense qu'en tout cas il n'a plus la
force propulsive qu'il avait il y a cinq
ans et donc moi je souhaite que ils
comprennent que il peut être celui qui
aide la gauche a retrouvé en fait les
affaires et que cette surenchère
permanente cette façon de disqualifier
le voisin en permanence pour essayer de
se pousser du col n'a aucun sens donc si
on veut enfin c'est toujours pareil
c'est moi je suis toujours épaté par
exemple sont très radicaux dans les mots
qui vous disent voilà donc un socialiste
pour monsieur mélenchon c'est déjà un
homme de droite très bien mais en face
si nous mêmes sommes déjà des hommes de
droite avec qui veut-il gouverner est-ce
que c'est avec ses 6 % des élections
européennes qui est pense qu'il a
gouverné la france et même s'il en avait
le double comme ça tu as sondages sans
le lui fait enregistrer ses provinces
ans il est en tête à gauche oui pour
l'instant parce que vous avez des offres
qui sont des offres 10 juillet en tête à
gauche sociale et écologique donc il
serait largement en tête mais même en
admettant qu'il fasse 12 % peu importe
je sais pas c'est 12% vous faites quoi
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas la
présidentielle mais même si par un
hasard mystérieux vous arriviez à vous
qualifier avec 12% à la présidentielle
au second tour parce que tous on était
tombé très bas mais comment vous
gouverner un pays ensuite si vous voulez
vraiment transformé s p il faut trouver
la majorité il majorité c'est pas
simplement la sphère de bien de deux
effets de levier en permanence en
espérant bien voilà le parti socialiste
bouge encore il n'est pas mort il n'est
pas mort et il vit il vit bien et je
pense que les grandes idées ne meurent
jamais merci merci à lundi d'abord si
faire juste rapidement on va parler de
la proportionnelle parce que c'est 2022
l'élection des députés vous avez dit
récemment que c'était un peu trop tard
pour la mettre en place d'ici le livre
de richard ferrand présenter un sens et
céréales il estime lui qu'il ya une
fenêtre encore possible jusqu'en juin et
françois bayrou du modem qui tient
mordicus à
à la proportionnelle enfonce le clou
hier par exemple sur france inter il a
proposé une solution à cette solution
s'est par exemple d'organiser un
référendum sur la proportionnelle au
move le même jour que les
départementales et régionales qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez non mais c'est
enfin je suis un peu consterné par ces
débats parce que on est en pleine
pandémie
on est à un moment où les françaises et
les français se demandent comment ils
vont continuer à vivre il avait des gens
qui semaine après semaine dont une seule
obsession le mode de scrutin
franchement c'est lunaire est par
ailleurs si vous voulez voir ce débat là
on peut la voir
moi je ne suis pas opposée ce débat mais
vous ne pouvez pas la voir
indépendamment de ce que sont nos
institutions donc pas régime pour
réaliser à la fois une constitution et
un mode de scrutin c'est ce que j'ai
appris que j'étais étudiant en droit
donc et je pense que mes enseignants
avait parfaitement raison il ya des
équilibres à trouver vous ne pouvez pas
dire simplement sa propre rationnelle
pour 10 départements et puis le reste au
scrutin majoritaire enfin tous est une
improvisation manifeste et qui ne mène
nulle part
on va accueillir dans les deux
parlementaires qui vont débattre avec
vous bonjour messieurs
et je présente nos invités bonsoir jean
alain colas roi et bonsoir fils dominati
sur ce plateau je vais vous présenter un
par la gente cola roi vous êtes député
la république en marche de l'isère vous
êtes un spécialiste des questions climat
notamment parce que ça c'est un sujet
qui vous tient à coeur et vont soir
philippe dominati redon soir dont vous
êtes sénateur apparenté les républicains
de paris et vous êtes vous plutôt un
spécial des questions de police et de
sécurité tout ça on va en parler mais
alors il ya un sujet que vous avez
évoqué avec audi et ford est commencé
jean-charles collard wap part aux
soviétiques
vous pourrez réagir tout de suite
philippe dominati c'est sur le projet de
loi qui va parce que selon que vous
placer l'un ou l'autre pour vous c'est
urgent pour vous c'est moins urgents
donc ça peut être très intéressant
qu'olivier effort et vous répondre oui
mais c'est vrai que 2021 ça va ça va
être une année extrêmement forte sur le
front du climat
il y a le projet de référendum vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure et je vous
remercie d'avoir clarifié le fait que
vous seriez favorable il y a le plan de
relance avec les 30 milliards d'euros
consacré au verdissement de l'économie
et j'étais moi à grenoble cet après midi
on inaugure des bâtiments qui sont
rénovés et ça ça va dynamiser et puis il
ya cette loi climat et résilience et je
vous ai sentis hésitants alors même que
ces lois qui a été travaillé avec les
citoyens de la convention comme jamais
une loi inédite
et puis avec beaucoup de réformes qui
vont dans le bon sens et si j'en crois
d'ailleurs vous savez les républicains
qui présente des amendements de
suppression sur quasiment tous les
articles
reprenant les inquiétudes de certaines
filières économiques
on voit bien que cette loi elle va déjà
loin il faut l'enrichir mais je trouve
qu'on pourrait être vous pourriez être
plus clair sur le fait que vous allez la
beauté et qu'ensemble on va progresser
moi j'admire cette rhétorique de la
république en marche en fait tout est
toujours formidable effraie toujours qu
en fait on soit d'entrée de jeu d'accord
avec ce que vous proposez d'abord vous
dites c'était bosser avec la convention
climat la réalité c'est que vous avez vu
la note qu'ils ont infligé aux projets
de loi et qu'il considère qu'il n'a même
pas la moyenne
laquelle ne se reconnaissent même pas
dans le projet qui est proposé bon j'ai
sur la mesure de réforme de la
constitution et reprise telle quelle
ils ne mettent même pas dix sur dix y
mettre six sur dix donc ce système
d'avant sa soeur il faut il faut le
regarder
à travers deux éléments dans la réforme
dans la constitution une partie que vous
avez retenu une partie vous n'avez pas
retenu sur le thé en bulles mais c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet c'est simplement
pour vous dire que en fait il ya quand
même pas vous ne pouvez pas prétendre
qu'ils vous soutiennent et qu'ils sont
parfaitement en ligne avec ce que vous
proposez moi ce que ce que je lis dans
ce projet c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
points sur lesquels en fait on aurait
aimé que les choses soient ce soit clair
vous me demandez de la clarté moi je
voudrais tu as raté par exemple sur
pourquoi est ce que par exemple il n'y a
rien sur l'objection de rénovation
globale des logements sur le portier
environnementale
ce sera fait sur les infrastructures
ferroviaires sur le prêt à taux zéro
pour les véhicules peu émetteurs sur la
tva réduite sur les produits locaux sans
taxation des produits en outre à
transformer sur les chèques alimentaires
sur la tva réduite sur les billets de
train voilà des sujets sur lesquels la
convention avait relancé et pour
lesquels il n'y a malheureusement pas ce
que nous voulions dans ce texte donc
voilà soyez clair reprenait aussi ses
propositions parce que nous avons besoin
d'aller vite
le projet de texte a été bâtie sur la
base d'un d'une volonté 40 % d'émissions
en moins
en 2030 nous allons avoir des
obligations européennes qui vont être
encore supérieur à celle là or on sait
très bien que la france n'arrive même
pas à tenir ses obligations actuelles
donc là on est enfin voilà il faut
maintenant il faut accélérer il faut que
mais il nous aurait échappé que le
travail de la convention citoyenne a été
fait entre septembre 2019 et 2020 et que
nous légiférons aujourd'hui en pleine
crise économique
donc est ce que vous vous êtes pour des
mesures encore plus punitives sur
l'aérien à un moment donné où le trafic
est quasi nul
et vous vous avez
des industries et des salariés qui sont
quasiment à l'arrêt est très inquiète
donc moi je pense qu'on peut progresser
sur des mesures la rénovation des
bâtiments par exemple ou d'autres
mesures
mais attention à ne pas être jusque
boutiste et à vouloir faire croire qu'il
faudrait être punitif avec des secteurs
économiques qui aujourd'hui sont à
l'arrêt quand même moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous sur le fait
qu'il fallait pas être punitif je vais
prendre un exemple concret j'étais dans
les fonderies du poitou qui fabrique en
fait des carter pour les camions diesel
et il avait une partie de notre
entreprise qui fabrique des diesels
aluminium notre parti en fonte sur la
partie aluminium ils ont pu se restaurer
cycle et dans les hybrides pour la
partie fonte c'est plus compliqué et
donc est là qu'est ce qu'on fait
évidemment est ce qu'on sacrifie les
salariés s qui sont la variable
d'ajustement de la transition écologique
moi j'aimerais et c'est ce que je plaide
est déjà au moment des élections
européennes qu'il y ait un mécanisme qui
sont celui du chômage partiel qui fut
invite inventé par les allemands mais
eux ils étaient assorties d'autres
choses à dire que pendant le fait du
chômage partiel pendant le temps libéré
vous formez les gens à leur métier
d'après est donc là vous avez quelque
chose qui permet des transitions et où
les salariés ne sont pas regardées
justement ils ne sont pas bien on est
d'accord sur les formats dominati vous
écoutiez ce cet échange avec gourmandise
si j'en vois votre regard
mais ça se voit pas ce que vous vous
dites bon tout ça c'est bien joli mais
c'était pas en soi une priorité en ce
moment
écoutez moi je vous écoute depuis le
début de l'émission vous étiez souvent
en phase avec l'action du gouvernement
parfois pour des raisons de
responsabilité sanitaire sur d'autres
sujets et en réalité moi ce qui me gêne
c'est que depuis huit ans c'est à peu
près la même politique
vous avez voté des budgets pendant cinq
ans sous l'autorité d'un ministre des
finances parfois qui s'appelait emmanuel
macron et puis au bout de trois ans vous
diverger moi j'ai le sentiment que le
président de la république a très bien
retenu la leçon de françois hollande à
12 mois des élections présidentielles il
y avait eu la coop 21 sous françois
hollande avec emmanuel macron il ya
cette nécessité deux référendums
je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence
la liste des sujets que vous avez évoqué
sur l'écologie c'est une réalité
effectivement selon un processus très
long mais moi je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qui différencie le parti
socialiste de la majorité présidentielle
parce qu'en réalité on retrouve les
mêmes acteurs on retrouve à peu près la
même politique
les mêmes engagements économiques est en
réalité j'ai l'impression que vous vous
disputez un peu sur l'épaisseur du trait
moi je dominati vous êtes formidables le
premier ministre il est bientôt de chez
vous lemay se connaissent et part pour
veiller l'économie ne connaissez pas
c'est facile de prendre qu'à moi non
plus je ne sais pas ministe c'est
vraiment le connaissez pas emmanuel
macron avant qu'il devienne ministre non
plus d'envoyer vous ne connaissiez pas
c'était votre ministre est le théoricien
et de nummi guéna de françois hollande
je ne connaissais l'élitisme général
adjoint des musées je ne connaissais ni
ses finances parce que je vous dise et
jean castex viennent chez vous le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
vient de chez vous le ministre
d'intérieur diane chez vous enfin je
pourrais continuer à la liste longtemps
comme ça et je peux même vous dire que
pourquoi je ne suis pas avec ce
gouvernement
tout simplement parce que moi je ne suis
pas d'accord que la politique fiscale
qu'ils ont conduite mais que vous vous
avez voté je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ce qu'ils ont fait sur l'asile et
l'immigration n'est que vous avez voté
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la
politique qu'il mène sur la sécurité les
protons vous voulez voter encore donc la
question c'est effectivement qui est
d'accord avec toi sur le travail qui
avoue t-elle europe et nico pas moi vous
avez voté loi pénicaud sur la question
de la sncf
moi je n'ai pas voté la loi sncf vous
avez voté la loi sru dominati vous
interroger sur était très timide
moi j'étais contre l'aris envie de
dominer t il voulu interroger sur
l'écologie en dix ans
ces préparations de la suite sur
l'écologie en réalité le catalogue sur
l'écologie des montres à mes yeux qu'en
réalité vous êtes les mêmes acteurs dans
l'assemblée nationale actuelle je dirais
en été il ya une rupture au sein du
parti socialiste
il ya une rupture entre les
sociaux-démocrates et les démocrates
sociaux la méthodologie de gouvernement
exactement la même les déficits budget
après budget s'élève même ligne
politique maintenant mener dans ce pays
depuis huit ans avec les mêmes dérapages
les mêmes visite à l'europe les mêmes
engagements vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne en disant nous allons
remettre de l'ordre dans nos finances
publiques est en réalité je crois que
vous confondez avec votre propre parti
c'est vous qui tenez un discours
et puis assez attention parce qu'elle
était monsieur woerth
les alliances du ps montre tout le
contraire le ps aujourd'hui dans est
allié avec europe ecologie les verts
avec la france insoumise et souvent
d'ailleurs est à la remorque de la
france insoumise qui sont des radicaux
qui sont des décroissants qui sont
contre l'économie de marché qui sont
contre l'armement des polices
municipales ou qui sont parfois dans le
déni sur les sujets de laïcité ou de
sécurité donc n'essayons pas de se
renvoyer la balle moi je crois qu'elles
sont très claires je vais vous mettre
d'accord je vais vous mettre d'accord
tout de suite on va et est allié avec
qui au municipal
bon ben voilà c'est simple vous étiez
ensemble à bordeaux à lyon et c'est vous
qui avait fait alliance a nice c'est
vous les expériences et aux prochaines
régionales si je comprends bien en paca
vous voulez faire comme un geste comme
une menace à londres d'endroits vrai
dans les hauts de france vous êtes
alliée à la france et insoumise
si vous aviez vous allez voir que
derrière
et moi je me cache pas je n'en dis que
je dis que je ne suis rien de ce que
décide si vous dites que vous n'êtes pas
ensemble moi je dis non
si la public en marche et la république
a malheureusement à la fois sur la
politique que vous conduisez j'en ai
fait la démonstration sur les hommes qui
conduisent principalement la potée de la
nation j'en ai fait la démonstration et
sur les alliances que vous conduisez
mois après mois dans les élections
locales vous le montrer aussi donc
maintenant ne venait pas fallait
politiciens en expliquant que ces
machins qui à l'équipe non moi je suis
sur un politicien je suis étonné une peu
les oliviers où je suis limité de
gestion budgétaire
j'ai toujours dit ce que je faisais et y
compris quand je m'allie avec les
insoumis comme vous dites ce que je ne
nie pas dans les hauts de france sur un
programme régional
je ne m'empêche pas de dire mes
désaccords avec la face insoumise non
plus sur la question de la laïcité comme
vous dites à l'instant et j'ai été le
premier à voir a dit qu'il y avait des
ambiguïtés dans leurs discours bien
avant que quiconque en face vient le
procès oui mais ça c'est fondamental
c'est quand même un en-avant talent vous
voyez sur le gros sûreté nucléaire sur
la sur le lien avec l'économie marcher
si on veut développer davantage que le
roi ne faites rien vous parler du
nucléaire
on va parler de zdf justement rester un
sujet lui tient à coeur sur le projet
requis 10 qui prévaut où il est prévu
que les sur les visées en trois bien sûr
bah oui c'est un sujet important parce
que je trouve qu'on dit on devrait se
retrouver pour essayer de sauver
l'avenir d'edf
trois dates d'abord 1999 2000 c'est
l'ouverture du marché européen ça se
passe sous lionel jospin et avec des
ministres communistes d'ailleurs et jean
luc mélenchon dans le gouvernement
2004 c'est l'ouverture du capital d'edf
jusqu'à 30% aujourd'hui il est ouvert à
16% mais il ya une possibilité jusqu'à
30% et ensuite 2012 c'est l'accès au
nucléaire historique qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire avec cette réforme et recule
on veut sécuriser la filière du
nucléaire en réhaussant l'accès au
nucléaire historique en donnant un prix
réévalué on veut sécuriser les
concessions hydrauliques et je peux vous
dire qu'en isère c'est un sujet majeur
en permettant à edf de renouveler ces
concessions il souhaite une négociation
âpre avec l'europe
et troisièmement on veut cantonner
uniquement la partie qui est ouverte au
capital à une petite partie d'edf
les renouvelables et une partie des
réseaux et pas à tout df comme
aujourd'hui
donc en fait c'est une réforme vous
devriez nous soutenir on veut sécuriser
l'avenir de
df et je ne vois pas ce soutien est ce
que là vous n'êtes pas dans la politique
politicienne par rapport à ce dossier
moi je suis toujours fidèle à ce que je
pense et donc sur ce réseau historique
que les français ont payé avec leur
argent qui nous appartient à toutes et à
tous et un tram c'est un bien commun je
souhaite que ce bien commun le demeure
je souhaite que nous nous confions pas
demain l'avenir alors très simple en
train de conduire la transition
écologique que nous devons la conduire
en tout cas je ne souhaite pas que les
outils la transition soit confiée à des
mains qui ne serait pas forcément celles
qui peuvent nous aider à la conduire
dans de bonnes conditions
je ne souhaite pas que ce soit notamment
une forme de privatisation rampante qui
conduisent derrière à ce que sur les
tarifs sur sa longue de date
infrastructures qu'il faudrait ou
préservés ou construire etc
les choix ne dépendent pas d'autre at
heart historique dans les conditions qui
sont celles que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne fais pas confiance à ce
gouvernement pour contenir cette réforme
je vois que toutes les femmes que vous
avez conduites jusqu'ici elle avait même
objectif
vous avez cherché à vendre ce qu'on
appelle communément les bijoux de
famille mais vous vous rendez compte que
vous avez quand même qu'yves attiser la
française des jeux c'est le rivage aux
pins qui a le plus privatisé les filtres
ont pas n'importe quoi mais pas nommer
le patron de surveiller votre avis c'est
aussi celui mais j'assume parfaitement
cet héritage alors il simplement que
quand vous semez rendez vous compte que
vous avez privatiser la française des
jeux il ya une machine à cash il suffit
juste de faire jing tous les ans si vous
avez confié ça au privé c'est quand même
incroyable vous avez voulu faire la même
chose avec adp et s'il n'y avait pas eu
cette grande mobilisation
on en serait déjà à l'avant la dp je ne
comprends pas et par ailleurs si vous
voulez avant même que il ya des sujets
sur lesquels moi je ne partage pas le
point de vue qui a été défendu parfois y
compris par des socialistes
je ne suis pas sûr que il fallait
privatiser les aéroports par exemple de
toulouse et voir aujourd'hui ce sont les
chinois qui après l'avoir à l'avoir
acheté cha cha le revendre et c'est en
bonne condition pour eux mais
déstructurant complètement notre propre
parc donc oui je souhaite que nous
soyons clairs qui est des principes
clairs et si les principes sont claires
nous pourrons suivre pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas
philippe dominer
si vous vouliez parler vous plutôt des
questions de sécurité j'étais tout alors
que c'est trop l'humeur en fiscalité et
de police qui était un petit peu évoqués
tout et leur écho aux propos d'eric vous
allez pouvoir aller plus loin j'ai
entendu c'était à peu près sur la même
ligne puisque en réalité vous avez fait
allusion à nicolas sarkozy
il y a avec la suppression des effectifs
c'est-à-dire on a entendu cela pendant
tout le quinquennat de françois hollande
il ya eu trois ministres de l'intérieur
avec emmanuel macron depuis je dirais la
crise du terrorisme et de l'immigration
en réalité via une dizaine d'années
lorsqu'on prend dix ans en arrière le
budget de mission sécurité le personnel
le titre de représenter 80% du budget de
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale et le reste fonctionnement
plus investissements de 20%
dix ans après ces 90 10
en réalité une augmentation des salaires
de 23% mais que 2 6% des effectifs et
dix ans après pour plus de monde
l'investissement lui n'a augmenté que de
0 4%
en réalité ce que je dénonce et traiter
l'air d'une manière générale se produit
dans ce domaine très particulier qu'est
la police et la gendarmerie nationale
c'est en réalité les mêmes hommes la
même politique
les mêmes hauts fonctionnaires qui mène
le jeu dirait la politique de sécurité
de la france
d'ailleurs il ya eu le livre blanc de la
saison si bien qu'il a dit cela juste en
même pas un mois
on n'est pas si nouveau les réunions de
buffo le président la république écrit
au secrétaire général du syndicat des
policiers de gauche
moi j'aimerais savoir la boutique qui ce
qui vous différencie en matière de
sécurité de la politique de ce
gouvernement parce qu'en réalité
encore une fois c'est la différence avec
dix lits en belgique et la différence
qu'il ya entre vous et moi c'est que les
huit dernières années
moi j'ai contesté le fait qu'il n'ait
pas ses moyens et que vous pendant cinq
ans vous avez quand même voter les
budgets précédents
mon effort je ne sais même plus quoi
vous répondre temps j'ai l'impression
que on a quittés
la planète terre en fait je sais pas où
vous êtes je sais pas sur quelle planète
vous vivez c'est gérald darmanin
n'aurait misé sur l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui a été jusqu'à son entrée au
gouvernement
excusez moi le premier le ministre de
l'intérieur c'était gérard collomb ça
vous dit quelque chose
après c'était je crois monsieur
castetner que vous connaissez bien
gérald darmanin qui est là depuis
quelques mois qu'il est le responsable
mais plus je râle t norman un profit
d'un plan de relance pour essayer de
trouver un peu les ouvre donc vous vous
êtes dans la continuité sur gesse
répondent au lycée si la continuité
c'est de retrouver de recruter à nouveau
dans le renseignement dans la
gendarmerie et dans la police me
recruter oui ça c'est continuer mais je
l'assumé on en faire une et on a recruté
dix les postes diminue depuis 2002 là où
je suis dans la continuité avec ce que
vous vous avez fait c'est que vous vous
avez supprimé des postes 13100 nicolas
sarkozy donc moi je veux bien mais
j'aurais fait dans la continuité et là
c'était for latin de sécurité il ne
devrait pas nous diviser nous a proposé
il devrait bien sûr et se dire quel est
le sens de dire ceci je suis plus
monsieur plus monsieur plus monsieur
plus mais moi je suis comme tous les
français je tiens ma sécurité je tiens
celle de maisons sans et celle de ma
famille mais vous parlez de sincérité
alors lorsque vous venez de saint cyr
8,6 sincérité vous obligerait à dire
lorsqu'on crée un agent supplémentaire
on lui donne les moyens on lui donne une
voiture on lui donne des armes on lui
donne les moyens investis c'est ce que
vous avez fait est ce qu'ils continuent
à se faire sur le président macron c'est
que lorsqu'on crée trois postes
supplémentaires ont supprimé une voiture
on est passé je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
de 80% pour les frais personnels à de
20% pour le fonctionnement et
l'investissement à moins de 10%
les récriminations les grèves de
policiers le ras-le-bol en réalité des
forces de sécurité ce sont les mêmes que
sous françois hollande vient il de
réforme on le se répondent olivier faure
et pourquoi les ministres qui sont les
mêmes l'ancien directeur de keller née
de cazeneuve
c'était le directeur général de la
police il ya encore quelques olives
pourquoi d'un seul coup vous êtes un
braquage
nous comptons pas encore quel est votre
projet sur ce sujet vous parliez
s'installer mais enfin écoutez ce qui
vous différencie j'ai compris qu'en fait
vous étiez venu pour dire que j'ai tel
emmanuel macron que plus exactement je
suivais sa politique que j'étais
d'accord avec tout j'essaie de vous
montrer dans cette émission que j'étais
plutôt cohérent avec que ce que nous
pensons et à chaque fois que nous sommes
en accord nous disons nous sommes
d'accord que nous ne le sommes pas on le
dit aussi
et j'ai l'impression que dans ce
quinquennat j'aurais fait la
démonstration que plus souvent c'est
vous qui avez été d'accord avec le
gouvernement parfois je lui étais peut
souvent à vrai dire
et ben voilà c'est tout c'est aussi
simple que ça et puis les français
jugeront nous il faut peut-être à la
politique politicienne franco français
n'en peuvent plus des gens posent une
question juive on va aller faire un
détour maintenant par le figaro live
nous attend vincent roux bonsoir vincent
vous allez nous dire vous comme tous les
lundis soir vincent ce que vos lecteurs
internautes ou nous téléspectateurs ont
retenu de l'actualité ce qui commente le
plus sur le figaro live gelé des
chiffres devant moi mon cher francis
olivier faure ce qui est très commentée
c'est la réaction choqué des
britanniques à la dernière une de
charlie hebdo on y voit une caricature
de la reine écrasé ma mégane maria delle
comme derek lowe a lancé le policier qui
a étouffé georges floyd est ce que vous
aussi levier fort vous êtes choqués ou
dit comme les britanniques choqué
franchement charlie hebdo est un journal
satirique et donc il choque en
permanence
rappelez vous pour le général de gaulle
c'était bal tragique à colombey pour les
musulmans on le sait pour le pape il a
été moquée si souvent que et cetera donc
la reine d'angleterre n'a pas raison d'y
échapper
voilà et donc ils cherchent à faire se
conjuguer deux actualités celle de
george bush aux idées puis parce que
c'est celle du racisme avec celle de la
famille royale
si ça fait rage
c'est justement fait pour ça c'est fait
pour faire réfléchir ya des gens qui
comprennent ce qu'est la satire il ya
des gens qui ne comprennent pas on n'est
pas obligé d'aimer
personne n'est obligé d'acheter charlie
hebdo ceux qui n'aiment pas ils
n'achètent pas à 100 vous vous aimez
vous aimez pas ça dépend jeu pas
toujours pas des fois ça me fait rire ça
ne fait pas plier force et elle ne fait
pas rire mais je la comprends je
comprends ce que ça veut dire c'est moi
je suis cette très loin pour tout vous
dire mais je comprends que pour que vous
ayez un petit fils et une et sa femme
qui décide de quitter les attributs de
la famille la couronne britannique sait
que certainement y avait de bonnes
raisons de le faire et en parlant de
racisme dans la famille royale dans
l'incident la famille royale et
malheureusement ça n'est pas ce serait
pas la seule famille au monde où les
choses existent donc ces histoires qu'on
rencontre tous les jours
et oui c'est bien de faire prendre
conscience y compris sur le fait que la
discrimination c'est pas seulement au
travail c'est parfois dans la famille et
je les mets les plus grandes et les plus
grands et même les plus grandes familles
mais je sais pas si elles sont plus
grandes chaque concert pas plus grande
que la mienne mme royal s'est passé je
suis républicain donc oui vous savez ce
que c'est et famille royale je n'ai pas
pu su royal mais enfin moi je me sens
tout ça chez république au même niveau
merci vincent merci vincent de nous
avoir posé cette question de du figaro
live merci jean charles cola roi merci
philippe dominati est devenu sur ce
plateau pour débattre avec olivier faure
et merci olivier faur d'avoir participé
à audition publique une heure ça passe
vite
votre mission l'a dit beaucoup de choses
mais vous avez dit beaucoup de choses
audition publique revient en direct
lundi à 19h30 vous pouvez décider à
retrouver sur les sites internet de lcp
de public sénat et sur le figaro l'âge
bonne soirée merci et un avis
[Musique]